and eleven thousand five hundred year
old infant has been unearthed in Alaska
and sunrise girl child's DNA suggests
that rather than several migratory waves
over time all Native American ancestry
traces back to one massive migration and
to breed plants that use water more
efficiently
researchers at Iowa State University are
measuring exactly how long it takes for
corn plants to move water from their
roots to their leaves using graphene
plant tattoos Vsauce coming here this is
mine
[Music]
the world's first photovoltaic
Expressway has debuted in China ki loo
transportation Development Group has
built a one kilometer stretch of road
that has a bottom layer of insulation a
middle layer of solar-powered batteries
and a top layer of transparent concrete
the electricity will power highway
lights cameras and signs but the
developers are hoping that it will power
electric cars and melt snow in the
future but the cost is high it's four
hundred and fifty eight dollars per
square meter compared to five dollars
for a standard asphalt road and the one
kilometer stretch will only create
enough electricity to power 93 homes for
one year so this has a long way to go
before it becomes like a thing
shrimp claws took 150 million years to
develop a study of 114 species of shrimp
has revealed how they're able to snap
their claws researchers at the
University of Alberta found what they
call extreme biology shrimp evolving to
make use of an air vacuum that stores
and expends energy in a snap shrimp use
the snapping motion to communicate
attack prey and defend themselves so
that 150 million years was totally worth
it and shrimp are delicious millions of
diabetics could benefit from a skin-like
surface currently diabetics have to
prick their skin to monitor blood sugar
levels not only is it painful but it can
result in infections and other
complications but researchers in Beijing
have found that ultra thin skin like
biosensors can reliably monitor glucose
levels in a non-invasive way which means
more comfort and better monitoring
twenty years ago a Popo started training
hero rats to detect landmines and
diagnose tuberculosis and they're
getting more efficient it takes four
days for a lab technician to evaluate
100 samples of spud them or for a
minesweeper to cover an area the size of
a tennis court a hero rat can do either
job in just 30 minutes
research and development includes
teaching rats to indicate the presence
of minds by flipping a collar switch in
identifying the presence of new
diseases so thanks rats we tend to think
of robots as rigid metal creations for
now the Keplinger research group at the
University of Colorado is developing
soft robots that mirror the makeup and
movements of biological muscle tissue
soft robotics allows machines to be as
forceful or gentle as they need to be
and researchers say the muscle like
electrical actuators that make
industrial and commercial applications
possible can be produced now for about
10 cents humanity has built its first
platypus the male platypus has a
venomous fur on its hind feet that it
uses to compete with other males for
mates but until now no one has extracted
the venom Tim Faulkner of the Australian
Reptile Park successfully took a sample
of venom which includes a hormone that
may be useful in treating diabetics the
world's first DJ robot is spinning in
the Czech Republic a club in Prague
challenged robotics manufacturer cuca to
make a robotic arm that controls the
action and can respond to the crowd the
challenge was accepted but the robot
music revolution isn't happening quite
yet the club is alternating between
human and robot DJ's every hour do tiny
sea turtles that hatch on the beach get
tired when they don't make it to the
water quickly enough researchers at
Florida Atlantic University put them on
a treadmill to find out sea turtles
crawl toward the light which means urban
glows can disorient them
FAU researchers found that the turtles
crawl rest and keep crawling even after
hours of effort they're little crawling
machines and as a wise zombie child once
said I like turtles
at Columbia University's robotics and
rehabilitation lab exoskeletons are
helping train people to walk again the
goal is to be able to build and design
lightweight variable exoskeletons an
exoskeleton that doesn't have explicit
joints that can either assist them in
their movement or train them so that
they could eventually walk without these
exoskeletons to come up with novel
inventions in science and technology we
need to develop our own toolkits and
framework
for understanding instead of just
blindly memorizing formulas brilliance
interactive problems are a great way for
you to really understand math and
science they have everything from number
theory to mastering casino blackjack or
this one I really like that explains
solar energy from the ground up we all
know that solar panels absorb the sun's
energy but what is it that they actually
do so click the link at the top of this
video's description to get 20% off your
annual subscription your brain will
thank you now I'm going to leave you
with an any mole robot that greets a new
friend in an interesting way and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
small calculator a really silent
electronic a really fast thinker one
that works anywhere on battery or plugin
one with all the calculator know how
you'll probably ever need introducing
the world's smallest electronic
calculator from the maker of the world's
most complete line sharp introducing the
elsi-8 world's smallest electronic
calculator by sharp price tag to match
3:45 complete LC 8 the answer
[Music]